great to have you here thank you for
looking forward to the game this weekend
I'm very exciting no just for me
especially for our friends ya know it's
a bit on the wall around the world you
but you know the NBA is increasingly
becoming a global player you think of
yourself for example from Africa how did
you get interested in this game as a kid
oh I didn't get a chance to play
basketball in a young as asia's so it
was not until I got to my sophomore year
to Georgetown in the first round no it
was when I was asked by the university
if I can't join the basketball team they
were like hey you're tall I really need
to play this sport yeah they just sort
of thrown kids walking okay it's going
back in for I'm sure you get this all
the time how tall are you I morning
serving food that's incredible in 7.3 so
you know when you look at a continent
like Africa there's got to be a lot of
the other tall you know people there as
well and there's there's an opportunity
for those kids to play you've been
active in instrumental in finding them
is you have done a great job as you say
I'm trusting a minute
the continent of Africa to give
opportunity to the next generation right
now as we are talking we have seen more
than 100 sun+ after complaints we have
come in and playing NBA and I believe
that as the year go past a number will
continue to increase in 1997 you founded
the Dikembe Mutombo foundation I know
you also serve as a global ambassador
for the NBA tell us about some of the
work you've been doing in Africa to get
people involved in basketball and to
help spread the word of the NBA if you
would on no level it's not just me doing
that I think I stopped with our
Commissioner Adam Silver with our
previous ohne dich first and we have
commit so much and resources to the
continent of Africa to see the growth of
our games we are very happy with the
number of the basketball court that will
build the number for school center
computer center and half concern that we
are doing in a continent and to make
sure that our game really becoming so
popular which is a BS in my MBA care
that's all we're all back well I mean
you're creating a new audience as well
right you're the game not just in Africa
but but around the world yes many our
games I've been watching more than it's
one in 20 countries and on the world and
right now we are going we are swimming
more than five games a day in a
different country in africa and some of
the country's kids are watching the game
full time today so you can see the
number of friends that we did it will
really happy with our popularity um I
know that you met with prince william
and the duchess of cambridge kate
middleton at a recent Mets game how are
the Royals helping you with your
philanthropy right now oh I think we're
you know we are working hand through
hands where I happen each other at our
MBA dinger
mba just allowed me to meet so many
people from the different world and the
world leader like the Dukes and the
duchess and we are trying to stop or
water column while I've trafficking this
morning elephant thousand thousand
elephants are being killing a continent
and the many wildlife also have been
killed and so we want to see I can we
stop the killing of elephant aware I
know especially also the monkeys and
gorillas are those are the danger pieces
of the world uh what is it the Africa
needs most right now the people's it's a
education health care yeah you know for
me I'm sick and tired see people dying
in a young age you know is that when I
see what happened to my mother when my
mother died because there was no
hospital closed market occur so I see
many kids are dying before age of five
and more continue to die for malaria and
mother dying again for Ebola so people
need to find a way to impress on a
continent to help these people so they
can he have a better life what now as we
are talking to us the mortality rate and
the continent is only 42 for men and for
the tree for women I think there's a way
we can impressed with both laughing a
continent well it's a great to see you
so involved in that effort thank you so
much Dikembe for being here and I would
you say you were 730 my food and I am
I'm 57 so that gives people as some some
perspective here my goodness thank you
thank you for ever meant I would
appreciate ur enjoy the game this
weekend I would make sure no just me and
my friend we're going to enjoy it